[Music]
let's stick with you peter so stay stay
there if you will because i want to
follow up as we start to explore some of
the questions that underpin to uh
today's debate and
you got to the heart of that with your
pitch and i want to push you a bit more
on it on what's the point of goods when
we've had enough and at some level you
can see that you know once you've got
shelter over your head once you've got
enough food to eat once you've got
clothes that will keep you warm you know
how much is there really beyond that but
i was struck by one particular word that
you used which was the word frivolous to
describe at least
some
consumerism
isn't the reality that human beings need
some frivolity in their life the life
that you've described of buying in a
utilitarian way you know what one needs
but not necessarily beyond that
is of course sufficient in terms of
needs but is it enough in terms of you
know people's wider happiness don't
people have some kind of right or need
to go beyond what's simply necessary for
everyday survival
well i've never said or never intended
to say
that um people should only focus on
needs
um you know of course the basics are
important but you know the basics you
know i think beyond the mere you know
the mere 2500 calories you need i think
you know i'm all in favor of people
having a
beer or wine or a chocolate cake or
whatever it's fine you know i'm not
against that at all i think
people should be able to have fun and
enjoyment in their lives
i'm just questioning the
extreme degree to which you know we have
moved uh where as you said initially
people have clothes in their closets
that they they've never worn for years
and years
um and you know why not recycle them
every now and then i give my clothes to
a charity shop and some of them um
end up being taken up and snapped up by
people
i once bumped into someone who was
wearing an item that i left in a charity
shop
they looked perfectly fine
the item was pretty much just as good as
you get brand new in a store
why why why just caught it or why throw
it away you know this this throwaway
culture
i think is
a mentality is is is just so so wrong
it's contributing
to the ecological crisis that the planet
faces and of course without you know
criminalizing the issue it's worth
noting that in recent years the idea of
vintage fashion has actually become much
more trendy the idea that people do
realize that reusing and recycling
particularly i have to say your 1980s
clothes which of course now are
absolutely at the height of what uh
young people looking to uh to wear so
what goes around comes around in that
and and you know i have several ties
that were bequeathed to me from my late
father
they were very fashionable in the 1930s
and 40s
and they've come back to fashion now so
you know
thank goodness you didn't throw them
away we just have to wait long enough
clearly deering has been dying to come
in theory please put you right in
a small point on this matter of clothing
for the last three centuries
so-called
capitalism
has organized
an enormous
market
in second-hand clothing
you will find in the now
poor parts of the world
and and those are often
improving thank god
the very clothes that you
disposed of in
london
and it's it's not happened
through
the
government it's not happened through any
kind of compulsion
it's happened because as you point out
peter
when
a
coat
is uh slightly worn um
and is handed into the uh
second-hand
um clothing store
it's still
perfectly
okay for
um
someone else and that kind of
ma that kind of a
matching
of consumption with availability
is what the so-called capitalist market
does
okay but david can i push you on that
because i'm still very surprised so far
in this discussion we haven't had a name
which at least amateurs like me would
have thought would have been right up at
the top of this debate and that is the
name of the
lost but not forgotten thorstein veblen
in other words the inventor of the
sociological idea or conspicuous
consumption and we remember the phrase
today even if we don't necessarily
remember the sociology
along with the idea that you know as an
economist you you will know better than
most of us the idea that people buying
what somebody's called positional goods
in other words
for a particular purpose of social
display social status
are these ideas conspicuous consumption
positional goods these sorts of things
part of something that we should be
condemning or are they actually part new
york so there's a no tell me why not
they're human
uh it it
early in the
history of
homosexians we find
evidence of
ornamentation
uh in fact
well i could
go into the archaeological
details but i won't i could
give you the example of
polished stone tools so
the the
we're like that and it's not evil
um and and as far as
positional goods are concerned i would
ask
everyone who hears this to
examine their own consumption
and ask themselves how much of it is
actually keeping up
with the joneses or indeed trying to
shame
the new joneses and i i i own 8 000
books
that's not because i'm trying to
uh be uh
uh show people that i'm
superior to them in in knowledge i
haven't read most of the books for one
thing
you probably wrote most of them judging
by your productivity but that's a
different matter thank you kindly busker
could i bring you in on this question
conspicuous consumption it does seem to
fulfill some sort of human need as
deitre is making out shouldn't we
acknowledge that rather than try and
deny it
um well yes i i'm less interested in
questioning people's consumption i'm
more interested in the conditions in
which people are treated when those
goods are being produced and i do think
there's a contradiction in what peter is
saying he's saying that
in medium to relatively high income
countries like taiwan like they are
happy and they consume less than we do
in let's say the united states but how
did these countries become medium to
high income countries they became medium
to high income
countries to having developmental states
and and also
constructing firms um uh that export to
to the west so so the fact that we swap
our phones every two years um
instead of hanging on to them for five
six seven uh years um
it benefits uh producers in in taiwan
and also has allowed the quality of life
that we've seen uh grow and develop in a
lot of these um these countries so you
know i think fundamentally having this
be a discussion about what is enough
what isn't enough and have it be about a
discussion about uh consumption turns
this into a zero-sum game and also even
this talk of
us having quote unquote too much in the
global north and not enough in the
global south again turns wealth creation
into a zero-sum game and obviously my
vision of a just society what we'll do
with our abundance and our wealth is
probably
closer to peter's vision of a just um
society
but i do think that we need this shift
in how we talk to shift about production
and again into the positive sum a win
away from the zero summary
well i think you know
it's undeniable that
what 20 percent of the world's
population
consume roughly 80 of the world's
resources
the 80 percent poorest 80 percent
are left with only 20 percent of the
world's resources now that kind of
inequality cannot be justified
particularly when
nearly a billion people on this planet
are hungry or malnourished without clean
safe drinking water or adequate
sanitation these are pretty basic
fundamentals and of course one of the
reasons why they are deprived is because
the resources are not being put into
tackle that poverty they're being put
into the global arms race military
spending is what 2 trillion u.s dollars
a year
globally um you know
and of course that we have these ultra
ultra rich individuals who have
unimaginable wealth
and they may claim to give bits away to
charity but
you know really the idea that people
have you know a dozen homes around the
world you know private jets private
yachts and so on i mean this is obscene
in a world where so many people are
actually dying thousands of people are
dying every day
because of dirty water or inadequate
food
um dairy i'll bring it back in in one
second but just
to make sure that we kind of move where
the conversation i think is going in
terms of how we might address these
questions i'd like to come up with
another question and then we'll bring
everyone back in so not to worry we have
not heard the last word from anyone at
this at this stage let's continue with
peter's theme but ask i want to turn it
back to you again
the question of what you might call the
morality of the if you don't call it
over consumption maybe overproduction is
part of the issue as well and of course
as you say we need to think about
ourselves and our societies and the
wider forces as being both
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas